there's one more case of partial
fraction expansion or decomposition
problems that you might see so I thought
I would cover it and that's the
situation where you have a repeated
factor in the denominator so let's see
it I've constructed a little problem
here it's 6x squared let me make sure my
pin is right 6x squared minus 19 X plus
15 all of that over X minus 1 times and
this is the thing that makes this one
especially interesting X minus 2 squared
so you might say gee yeah this is a
little bit different because what do I
do here I have this first-degree factor
but it shows up twice and it doesn't
make sense for example it wouldn't make
sense to do this a over X minus 1 plus B
over X minus 2 plus C over X minus 2
because if you did this the B and the C
will just add together because they have
the same denominator and you could just
do them as one variable you wouldn't
have to have two separate variables here
so this wouldn't make sense it's a
partial fraction expansion of this you
might want to maybe square this and view
it as a second degree term and do it
like you did in the previous example but
then you wouldn't have fully decomposed
this problem and so the answer here and
I'll just show you how to do it now
maybe leave it to you a little bit to
think about why it works is to decompose
it almost like this but instead of
having C over X minus 2 you're going to
have C over X minus 2 squared I'll try
to give you a little intuition about why
that happens
so the decomposition here is going to be
a over X minus 1 plus B over X minus 2
plus C over X minus 2 squared and the
intuition here is that if you were to
let's ignore this term right here but if
you were to add these two terms right
there you would you would get a partial
or you would get a rational function
that would end up having you know
something times X plus something and so
it would be consistent with what we did
in the second
partial fraction video where if you
would have a second degree term on the
bottom and in the numerator when you add
just these two parts let me let me
clarify what I'm saying now this is just
for intuition if you were to add just
these two parts here you would get you
know something times X plus something
all of that over X minus 2 squared and
that's consistent with what we did in
the previous video where we said if we
have a second degree term in the
denominator which this really is if you
were to expand this you should have a
first degree term in the numerator so
I'll leave that there that's a little
bit of a of a nuance and it's good to
think about why this works but with that
said let's just solve this problem let
me isolate actually let me erase some of
this stuff that I've written let me
erase all of that alright ready to work
on this problem so given that this is
the expansion now we just have to solve
for a B and C so if we were to add these
three fractions the common denominator
is the common denominator here is X
minus 1 times X minus 2 squared all
right this is a factor of that so the
least common multiple of this and this
is just this so it's just X minus 2
squared there and that's why we just did
this to begin with and the numerator is
going to be let me do it in a different
color a what we have to multiply a by a
times X minus 2 squared right if we
cancel these out you're just left with a
over X minus 1 plus B times X minus 1
times X minus 2 right if we cancel out
the X minus 1 and one of these X minus
2's 4 down here then you're just left
with B over X minus 2 plus C times X
minus 1 right if that cancels with that
we're left with C over X minus 2 squared
and all of this is going to be equal to
that up there in blue
is going to be equal to have to write it
smaller 6x squared minus 19 X plus 15
all of that over X minus 1 times X minus
2 squared and like we've done in every
problem so far the denominators are the
same so we can just set the numerator is
equal to each other and try to solve for
a B and C let me write that so we have
and I'm really just rewriting it a times
X minus 2 squared plus B times X minus 1
times X minus 2 plus C times X minus 1
is going to be equal to 6x squared minus
19 X plus 15 there you go and now we
have to solve for them and we can do it
just the way we've done the previous
problems we can pick choices for X that
make things cancel out nicely so if we
wanted to solve for a and we want to
make the B and the C cancel out if we
just have to pick X is equal to 1
because if X is equal to 1 this becomes
0 so C disappears this becomes 0 so this
whole term disappears and we're just
left with this and this so let's do that
so when X is equal to 1 we get let me
pick another color a times 1 minus 2 is
minus 1 squared is just 1 so it's a
times 1 so we can just leave the a there
this becomes 0 because this term right
here will be 0 if X is 1 this becomes 0
because that term would be 0 if X is
equal to 1 so a is equal to 6 times 1 so
6 minus 19 times 1 minus 19 plus 15 and
what is that - 19 plus 15 that's minus 4
plus 6 that is equal to 2 there you go
now let's try to solve for let's see
what can we do if we make X equal to 2
the a will disappear this whole term
will disappear because we have this
would be 0 so we could use that to solve
for C so if we say that X is equal to 2
X is equal to 2 then we get this term
would be 0 because that's 0 this whole
expression
zero because X minus 2 would be zero and
we're just left with C times 2 minus 1
so that's just 1 so C is equal to 6
times 4 right 2 squared so it's 24 minus
3819 times 2 plus 15
let's see 24 plus 15 is 39 minus 38 that
is equal to 1 we're in the homestretch
and now for B there's no obvious way to
make the other two cancel out without
making the be canceled out but we've
solved for everything else so we can
really just pick an arbitrary value for
X that'll make things easy to compute so
if we just pick X is equal to 0 that's
always something that can clear out a
lot of the hairiness of an algebra is
equal to 0 not 3 X is equal to 0 let me
do that in a different color if X is
equal to 0 then what do we have we have
a but a is 2 right 2 times 0 minus 2
squared so that's minus 2 squared so
it's 2 times 4 plus B that's what we're
trying to solve for we already solved
for everything B times minus 1 right 0
minus 1 is minus 1 times minus 2 plus C
times minus 1 so C times minus 1 is
equal to if well if x is 0 then this is
0 this is 0 is equal to 15 now we just
solve for B we get 8 let's see this is
plus 2 B all right
minus 1 times minus 2 is plus 2 minus oh
and we shouldn't have written the C here
we know what C is C is 1 right so this
is just a 1 so 1 times minus 1 is minus
1 is equal to 15 and let's see we have 2
B is equal to let's see 16 is equal to 8
B is equal to 4 dividing both sides by 2
so we're done so the partial fraction
decomposition of this right here is a
which we've learnt we've solved for
which is 2 so that equals 2 over X minus
1 plus b which is 4 plus 4 over X minus
2 plus C which is 1 over X minus 2
squared and what we did in this with the
repeated factor is true if we went to a
higher degree term so if we had you know
bla bla bla bla bla bla bla some
polynomial up there and it was all over
X - I don't know some number X minus a
to the I don't know to the 10th power or
let me get you know to the to the way
yes sure to the 10th power if we wanted
to partially 4 if we want to decompose
this partial fraction or expand it it
would be a over X minus a it's a
different a I'm just showing this 4 plus
B times X minus a squared + and you go
buhbuh buhbuh you'd have ten terms plus
you know I don't know what the tenth
letter of the alphabet is maybe it's H
or I or something I don't know let me
maybe it's j j over x minus a to the
10th so you can use that property in
general though you'll very seldom see
something like this because
computationally it would take you
forever to do it
the hairiest problem that you might see
with 3 variables on a on a on an actual
exam it's probably something like i
showed you in the lot previous example
or or what i just showed you right now
anything hairier than that you'd
probably end up using a computer but you
should know how to do it because if you
have a computer and you're solving a
real-world problem that is a lot more
complicated than this you should know
how to do it anyway hope you found that
a bit helpful